hammer der woche
eigentlich sollten hier in bitterfeld
wolfen in sachsen anhalt längst bagger
rollen und die straßen saniert werden
aber auf dem innenstadtring bitterfeld
ist kein bautrupp zu sehen hier auch
nicht und auch da nicht stolze 4,2
millionen euro fördermittel liegen für
die sanierung bereit aber die stadt ist
mit der planung nicht fertig deshalb
fällt der umbau aus das ist einfach ein
trauerspiel was hier abgeht
man soll sich doch mehr bemühen als
biokraftstoffe dann immer wieder was
dann doch nicht gehen obwohl es hätte
gehen können wahrscheinlich ist die
planung dann nicht richtig laufen das
ist eigentlich eine schlamperei muss man
sagen und das ist nicht gut für sachsen
anhalt bitterfeld wolfen
es ist schade weil das geld ist dann
eigentlich verschenkt absurd obwohl hier
nichts passiert steht das
baustellenschild immer noch in der
gegend rum
eigentlich sollte hier schon seit einem
jahr gebaut werden
der bau wäre zu satten 93 prozent
gefördert worden den löwenanteil hätte
die europäische union übernommen also
quasi ein geschenk an die stadt 2014
wurde das förderprogramm aufgelegt bis
spätestens 2023 müsste alles abgerechnet
sein
aber in bitterfeld bekommt man das nicht
auf die reihe die folge aus den dringend
erforderlichen neuen
versorgungsleitungen wird nix und auch
straßen und fußwege werden nicht
erneuert
stattdessen bröselte innenstadtring
weiter vor sich hin weil es ist schon
wirklich mies also wenn man etwas
geschenkt bekommt so viel geld sollte
man es auch ordentlich planen dass es
fertig wird bis die förderung hat vorbei
ist also ich verstehe es nicht traurig
ich finde das schade dass ich schätze
mal dass jemand geschlafen warum auch
immer
und da sollte vielleicht mal nach
gestoßen werden warum das so ist ein
interview vor der kamera lehnt man im
rathaus ab von einer städtischen
fehlplanung will man nichts wissen
schriftlich heißt es wir waren uns
bewusst dass es ein enger zeitrahmen ist
auch wenn das projekt nun zunächst
abgebrochen wurde kann auf dem
erreichten planungsstand aufgebaut
werden fragt sich nur mit welchem geld
die fördermittel sind jedenfalls futsch
also ich find's ganz ganz traurig dass
so viel geld eigentlich verschlammt wird
das finde ich schlimm das ist ärgerlich
einfach nur ärgerlich
bislang hat die planung 132000 euro
gekostet für die dringende sanierung
will die stadt jetzt nach neuen
geldquellen ausschau halten